l'épidémie de coronavirus nous
accueillons brigitte klinkert c'est la
présidente du conseil départemental du
haut rhin
l'un des départements les plus touchés
en france par la maladie elle est
interrogée par aurélie look est
aujourd'hui j'estime qu'il est bon
joueur aurait lui le quai bonjour à tous
alors on entendait depuis ce matin qu'un
couvre feu est mis en place à mulhouse
désormais est-ce que partout en alsace
partout dans grand test
il faut aller plus loin dans les mesures
de confinement c'est ce que réclame un
certain médecin alors j'ai pris
connaissance en effet le défiant de
confinement prises par la ville de
mulhouse
vous savez que la ville de mulhouse
connaît la situation la plus tendue et
que nous sommes actuellement en alsace
dans la phase la plus virulente du du
virus mais je dois dire aussi que si une
respections tous les règles de
confinement et les règles barrière qui
ont été édictées on n'aurait normalement
pas besoin de couvre-feu parce qu'on n'a
pas besoin de sortir de chez toi en
particulier entre 22h et 6h du matin
donc la consigne fait quoi qu'il en soit
rester chez vous parce que le virus se
propage très vite et nous sommes là dans
la phase la plus virulente
le confinement s'impose à tous et ne pas
sortir ça veut dire aussi se protéger
bien sûr soit dan mais celle-ci protège
les l'autre et surtout ne pas engager
les hôpitaux et les soignants qui sont
déjà aujourd'hui est pris alors soyons
tous talents d'heure juste un appel si
vous allez faire les courses
et bien vous faites les courses une fois
par semaine pas la peine de traîner dans
les rayons parce que c'est de là qu'il
ya le plus de risques lorsqu'on sort
donc on fait les courses et vous rentrez
du che le le décompte macabre un vous le
disiez se poursuit dans grand test des
victimes du coronavirus puisque nous
sommes dans une période très très très
virulente 261 11 morts hier déjà les
derniers messages des agents
sanitaire ne font plus de bilan dans le
haut-rhin ça veut dire que dans le haut
rhin
on ne compte plus vraiment le nombre de
morts liées aux coronavirus on arrive à
une situation catastrophique alors la
situation est en effet dramatique dans
le département ne sont malheureusement
le département le plus touché au niveau
national hier on comptait un peu plus de
70 décès dans les hôpitaux mais se
rajoutent malheureusement à ce décompte
macabre les décès qui peuvent avoir lieu
au domicile et notamment aussi des
personnes âgées dans les ehpad qui sont
également touchés par par le co lead
vous le savez il nous manque de lits
nous manque de lits de réanimation en
particulier nous évacuons actuellement
des malades vers d'autres hôpitaux
français aujourd'hui heureusement
l'hôpital de campagne de l'armée va être
mis en fonction et entier toute
particulière pour pour les soignants et
tout ce que justement weeds et vous tous
que les soignants vous le disiez il dit
sont au jeu tous les jours heure par
heure au service des malades et des
patients il va falloir les relayer un
moment de résine kert
c'est justement ce qui est envisagé
j'avais vendredi après midi le premier
ministre en ligne pour lui demander de
nous envoyer du matériel aussi des
respirateurs de réanimation et de nous
envoyer du personnel et il m'a répondu
que c'était en cours qu'il allait mettre
en oeuvre les moyens et qu'il nous
fallait qu'ils allaient nous envoyer des
réservistes sanitaires nous sommes aussi
en lien avec nos voisins allemands et
j'attends ce matin la réponse d'un
hôpital en lui allemand qui pourrait
nous envoyer une équipe de soins
intensifs dans l'hôpital de colmar et de
mulhouse pour venir a donc soutenir
soutenir les soignants et des zones hier
aussi apporté hier de matériaux pour les
relégués mais alors il ya le problème
des hôpitaux mais je voudrais aussi
souligner l de problèmes dans les ehpad
où là aussi les personnels sont épuisés
et où on va devoir mettre en place aussi
comme dans les hôpitaux du
psychologique au personnel je voudrais
avoir une pensée aussi pour toutes les
personnes qui sont dans le service aide
à domicile auprès des personnes âgées
auprès des personnes handicapées et tout
ce médecin mais aussi entreprises et
autres qui assure les fonctions vitales
vital pour notre quotidien il fait pour
les autres bannières toujours les
propres rappelle cette consigne un bien
évidemment rester chez vous ne sortait
que quand c'est absolument indispensable
merci à vous brigitte klinkert d'avoir
été en direct ce matin sur france bleu
lorraine nord et sur france bleu alsace
brigitte qu'une carte la présidente du
conseil départemental du haut rhin